oh my gosh meatball
[Music]
it is recording yeah
yeah okay oh damn good
hey hi
welcome back to the 54th episode
51st dates episode of uh
cats after dark the whole crew was here
today and someone smells really good
that's me is it you you know what's
going on fantastic oh you got the
whiskey
what do you got yeah he smells nice
thank you
what are you what are you going on what
is that i wear cool water
water is like so old school but i still
water yeah
what brand is that davidoff davidoff
yeah cool waters old school is fun so
old school but i love this one dude
that's like 90s yeah it is
that's why i was in high school i
haven't heard about that in a [ __ ]
minute typing uh
the guy comes out of the water with his
hair yeah yeah do you remember cool
water nick no you said we were on the
same age uh no my cologne at that time
was i got it from my eighth grade
teacher and it lasted like the one
bottle lasted through high school was
armani
no he like
that's a classic this guy was cool he
was only like 26 years old in eighth
grade like
we went and visited him like the week
after school that did and we like played
basketball with him and he just had that
on his desk he's like i'm not taking any
of this [ __ ] with me whatever sometimes
and i took the cologne and it lasted all
high school pretty much yeah how did you
do that i just i don't i like put out
spray when i go out
yeah like i don't i don't wear clone
every day usually after shave i just
don't like it when girls or guys will
spray something on them and they do more
than two spritz it's too much i feel
like you're pepe le pew where like the
the trail of scent is following you the
movie that's too much to spray and walk
it through yes yes exactly you got to
learn it though you got to learn it
because in the beginning i would be like
church yeah and drive it all over
like that you know dave david lucas
he loves like cologne and [ __ ] like that
you know he'll mix it mix like his
colognes up oh yeah some people yeah he
says it's like a scientologist yeah well
you know he explained it
to us as a way of uh he goes it's like
when you mix like spices yeah or drinks
it's just like that i go oh i never
thought of that
i i've always said about cologne my joke
would be like when people have it
overbearing it was like it's not to
bring them in it's to keep them close
hey
is that your is that your that's a joke
or that's your that's kind of like my
philosophy on set yeah yeah you should
make a commercial and use that
that is good i have white claw arriving
via pokemon
that is [ __ ] can i have one today
will you give me a water out of the
fridge yeah we'll keep rolling yeah okay
yeah yeah that's damage you you cool
water did you bring it up
my
chrome was so cute because i want to see
what that bottle looked like when you
what's okay for me when i was in i think
high school that's when the first time i
felt like
i saw a girl at a crush on i smelled her
perfume yeah and i remember it was
escape at the time it smelled so good
something called escape
it smells so good and i'm like oh my
gosh it kind of enhanced my crush
do you like dudes that have a certain
smell
i like due to smell clean i think i
always out of the shower like fresh
laundry um and like a freshly showered
yeah it smells really [ __ ] good to me
i prefer that over colombia
you find something so attractive about
if a man has like a signature cologne
that isn't very common because every
time if i go in to hug him i'll remember
that exactly and i know that no one else
smells like scent is so powerful i saw
something online where a guy will do
this thing where he will spray his
girlfriend's like knitting material
which is her favorite pastime so every
time she knits she thinks of him because
that scent is associated with him wow
that's like wow you're like training
your girlfriend like yeah it's like just
associated with good memories with him
very smart very manipulative machine
never leaving right everything's
actually like oh i miss him it's so
funny because isn't that what girls used
to do to guys with their sweatshirts oh
yeah you would spray it down
a dude sweatshirt it's like so he will
remember you but also so other [ __ ]
know what's good why does he smell like
victoria's secret that's me [ __ ] that's
like that song will you be in my heart
you know that one no
will you be
in my heart oh you'll be in my heart by
phil collins oh it's you me and my heart
and us you covered it you'll be amazing
yes for tarzan
i knew where we go it's
it's always embarrassing when i try to
sing something to let people know like
what the song is and they're like i've
never heard that song and then i go no
like then i'm going to be digging myself
into it
because obviously i'm not singing it the
best but you can sing so i'm surprised
you can't see it the way that you
remember it i think i was just being
lazy oh okay you know sometimes you
don't want to just sing it takes a
little effort yeah and then if you sing
it good then it's like
then what's the magic right you know
what's the [ __ ] what's the fun in the in
helping you find out what the [ __ ]
song is you should
they should guess it more than you
should yeah yeah all right i did sing it
pretty [ __ ] off
well
a little off a little off we still got
it yeah
it took a second you still got the right
lyrics i feel like that's really what's
important because if you got the right
no that was the circle of life
no there's
what's the ellen john song uh that one
is uh in the air tonight circle of life
that is circle of life no no elton john
yeah yes yes yes is it elton john's
circle alive uh
i'm pretty sure it is hey see if john's
saying circle i'll bet you guys right
now
he did he did thank you nick
there you go i no i thought he's saying
uh
unless he went
tonight
oh my god that is like that is right
what happened
no it was can you feel the love tonight
yes okay you're right
i was wrong
so so meatball
john's saying uh
you know we would get this answer a lot
quicker
magic mines
he's saying circle of life yeah
oh i still can't catch
go ahead meatball
jesus christ
so oh okay elton john [ __ ] saying
circle alive oh he did both i knew it
it's nice i didn't know that there we go
redeemed fully redeemed
the
i can't tell you how circle better it is
outside than in here why are you hot
like the lights
the lights oh i know why i know why you
oh episode 10 i took them yeah yeah is
this how do you feel right now
uh i took him at 210 and it's starting
to get weird hey are we recording yeah
okay what did you think
i didn't take anything no
he took streams
oh that door quote unquote
oh yeah if you don't shake that [ __ ] up
enough yeah you get it you get all the
grain yeah it's all the like leftover
matcha because it's really hard to mix
in
i get that feeling like as soon as i sip
it magic mine about to make the whole
day different wake up and go and get it
clarity when i think ashwagandha you
want him with a reading productive when
i
[Music]
this daily one-shot drink the
anti-procrastination
gun
[Music]
[Music]
you know sometimes it'll be at the top
yeah
you know what i mean you see you gotta
really shake the [ __ ] out of it
oh cheers
i'll wait for you yeah thanks chairs
just gotta make sure you get all that
grain off you know what i'm saying
yeah all the matcha in there all the
matcha all the [ __ ] ashwagandha
ashwagandha echinacea
sound like my cousins yeah
i'm just going to let you guys take over
right here
just keep feeling yourself bro
nick's got his white claws he's got his
mushrooms
we haven't smoked all day you haven't
smoked all day i was waiting hey i need
to clarify something dude yeah
okay i posted that i've been off alcohol
for eight years on my ig
that's off of alcohol
i smoke weed
okay are people saying you're not
actually sober no no no no no no no
you've worn yourself i just don't i
don't like saying that i'm sober because
i know
[Laughter]
yeah yeah no i know what you mean though
people get upset no it's not that i
don't want to i don't want to disrespect
those people that are actually
going through the programs
and
actually taking the time to like be
completely
sober all substances all substances
that's why i don't say i'm sober i just
say because at first i did i'm like i'm
sober you know
but
i was saying that you know but
but then i dabbled in weed again and i
was like i'm comfortable with this and
then i was still kind of saying i was
like wait don't do that [ __ ] is there
a difference between saying you're sober
versus straight edge i or are they the
same uh
it's the same straight edge is just more
of the
hardcore
uh culture okay parkour and punk rock
culture
that's that's what they you know and
it's like yeah you're when you say
straight edge it's identifying as like a
specific group like you're like i want
to be with these people like sober is
like people are probably people that
have had struggles
straight edge
most straight edged people
for the most part there's some people
that have like fallen off or whatever
but for the most part
the traditional like my like my boy toby
he's traditional straight edge like he's
never done anything in his life god so
that's that's his traditional
that's his weight the way he rolls you
know
so
but nick on the other hand
nick is the opposite
nick's on it he's got to put a sweater
on bro you know it's hot yeah i look fat
[Laughter]
t-shirt i really love it but it really
is a great shirt yeah i love that
huh i love that about a sweater oh yeah
take away the fat yes i'll do the same
thing but i'll clutch a pillow when i
feel like i look chubby oh my god
yes i will always pledge to that that's
why you were doing that earlier i just
do it naturally all the time so he used
to get so mad at me because after we
would be done hooking up i just like
it's a comfort thing for me and he
thinks i'm like scarred like he
traumatized me so he's like hey are you
okay like did i do something wrong like
no i just feel more comfortable yeah
cuddle me [ __ ] yeah
yo i'm that way every time i sit on the
couch right you gotta grab them just
like yeah let me get that let me get
that i know it's what they're for i know
it's normal for you to have rolls while
you're sitting down i just feel so
self-conscious about it yeah and
sometimes when we're on camera depending
on what angle it's at i just it's not
very flattering so i want something
there i'll put a jacket a pillow my bag
something has to be on my lap chin you
used to have to do it too yeah what hold
pillows yeah i still do it i can't sleep
without holding a pillow really yeah i
can't do you have a body pillow no just
a regular fluffy big pillow yeah you
just have an eye pillow a my pillow you
know
use promo code what uh they don't
sponsor us yet they would if they do
it'll be dark right
yeah i don't know
or what is it my pillow i'm trying to
think of the guy's name who runs it but
he's like he's like
super hardcore trump supporter and stuff
and like people like
dropped him from uh he was a former
crack addict we tried to get him on tvw
for the longest time
find the guy's name mike something the
guy's got a story who made my pillow and
it's just a very successful uh
i can't think of words the proofs are
kicking in hey was it was he on a shark
tank infomercial infomercial information
was
probably
it's my pillow mike he said anything
yeah
mike lindell
oh he's got it he looks crazy yeah
from here he looks like hitler yeah he
looks like crazy
the shrooms
i don't know i don't know if he has a
hitler god all things are possible he's
got an old white dude vibe he's giving
me mario vibes yeah mario like mario
luigi just kind of middle of america
didn't nick where you got hitler
and the top one with the yellow
background mm-hmm that looks like yeah
okay
it does not
you know good american man and
that makes him yeah you're right someone
got him from a bad angle if his second
hand was a little lower that'd be a
little questionable in this as well when
you guys started to lean into like the
alt-right stuff then uh david hogg
that uh crisis actor who said he was in
the the parkland shootings he started
his own pillow company called like it
was like
something pillow i don't know but it was
like a it was like a liberal pillow and
it failed right away really do you guys
know who david hogg is
a liberal
a liberal pillow yeah no he didn't
uh
this real life david hogg pillow
i called him a crisis actor he was a
survivor
i remember this kid he was a joke he was
a survivor of the parkland shooting oh
he resigned from possessed uh
progressives this kid yeah
i remember that hey i hate that kid too
oh is he is he not a good guy he's just
a [ __ ] twerp
yeah i haven't heard him talk about it
i don't know what the [ __ ] what did he
do wrong that's because ad block
uh he's all good
there we go
what did he what didn't he do wrong i
don't like him if you like listen to him
and he's just one of those people where
you're like i want to like punch that
perk yeah yeah i'm not trying and i'm
not trying to get all political or
anything like that but that's what i'm
saying i really don't like like he just
like ugh he just
seemed like he wanted to get attention
from that experience
where kids actually got killed but he
didn't get killed but he he became the
spokesperson for all of them and he
seemed like he just wanted the attention
yeah
he was at the party
but nick uh nick actually made me want
to bring this up so going on school
shootings uh all right perfect perfect
yeah what's up we're about to get our
showcase yeah what are you okay
speaking of school shooting speaking of
schools there you go
meatball meatball you can talk to any of
us at any time i'll never call you ugly
ever again
ever okay i'll cancel it all right
hey i didn't make a call then um no but
uh i would love to see the paolo
manifesto
from him it's just it's just writes
before the school it's just like
scribbles and nick after after dark
episodes
[Laughter]
just demented drawings yeah all right
let's let's see what you got to say
before we
uh figure out if we got to edit out or
not we don't um so going on school
shootings my i'm actually kind of proud
of my father for this
my dad came up with this technology oh
can we do it within the segment oh i
didn't know we were doing a segment i
told you but
well i just wanted to talk about the
cat's recommendations uh up to the top
so we can discuss like the the things
we're in the
tv shows so whatever we're enjoying
anything you want to like kind of
put out there don't wait then put it in
the air it's okay i should have stepped
on it i should have let it ride
that was hey blame that on the stream
yeah sure
not not the magic mind shrooms i think
the mushrooms are what let me
see my mistake
wow look at what it's doing yeah it's
killing my he's having a [ __ ]
experience right now i love it
but uh yeah so tell us about your dad's
stupid invention
nick nick is still there hey nick yeah
nick's here
he's nice
i knew
it made me think of it especially now
because you were mentioned florida and
him in his entire company is going down
to orlando to speak at a summit this
week he basically came up with this
technology that will help prevent school
shootings
and uh it launched today like and it's
been all over the news so it's basically
like i have like a couple of points if
one of you like yeah tell us about it so
it
so basically what it does is underfunded
schools that can't afford it his company
installs it for free
so that way if there's ever like a
school shooting their technology
is like so this is what he sent me it
gives real-time critical information to
first responders of people trapped in an
infrastructure and have a medical
emergency or if there's an active threat
located throughout the building so say
there was a shooter at thick boy studios
and we had this technology we would be
able to let whatever police department
that is in this area i don't know which
one that would be lapd calabasas pd or
whatever they would from their offices
they could see exactly where in the
building it is uh the shooter is and
they can contact the school and the
people who are
uh there to find out more information
about the shooter itself
it's like in a
dark night when
he
or is it yeah dark knight when he's like
he's got they use that technology that
that uses everybody's cell phone and he
can see what's going on even though he's
like blind do you guys know him it's
like echo location yeah yeah the echo
yeah yeah the echo location you know
what i you know what i i thought
i did not think that's what you were
going to say this invention was
what do you think it was going to be i
thought there was going to be this thing
that your dad created
and this is my brain you ready i think
my brain is like
i thought you're going to say he created
something
that basically no no that
anytime a firearm is on this like walks
on campus it could be detected
he wasn't aware that's what i thought
that's where my brain was going i was
like damn that's [ __ ] badass so that
was so i'm gonna do that invention well
no that's how this invention started
that's what he originally came up with
but to do that let's say you were going
to
uh dodger stadium what they would do is
they would install a
radio tower above it but
you would the problem with that is you
would have to retrofit every single gun
that there is with an rfid or rfd rfid
chip and
then if guns that don't have it no i was
thinking there was like this thing that
could detect firearm like it wouldn't
even happen
no no like you wouldn't even have to
ship the iphone like this
some type of sensor of a thing
that just like
can detect a gun immediately but that
that's only on the campus it does that's
that's what i was that's what i'm that's
what i was trying to say nothing you
don't even have to put a chip in a gun
or anything like that it just knows when
a gun's on campus and like alerts it
maybe yeah you know a loud alarm goes
off or some [ __ ] you know i want to help
you i have a new inventory oh okay
are we trying to outdo christian's day
yeah
and we're not worried about the
technology this is just my invention
yeah yeah this
and it's only on school campuses but
like
and it works for everyone but like if
someone shoots a gun and the bullet
comes
right before it gets to someone it knows
if you're innocent and if you're
innocent
then i like that then it just falls to
the ground
yes nick yeah
we're gonna be [ __ ] rich
technology
in his innocence
i would i didn't split hairs with your
thing that is also interesting you're
right you're right you're right
what's more feasible yeah
yeah
that is [ __ ] so
and
all of a sudden like your friend's gonna
be there but like he'll get shot yeah
yeah yeah he must have been a part oh he
was a dick
yeah yeah
who gets to determine what innocence is
though is there a handbook that we just
write like these are the black and white
rules
these are these are good questions i'm
not saying they're good it's the
software cat the software will recognize
it's a douchebag
algorithm there's something that you get
when
you go to the dmv
and it basically
checks your
your police records
and
based off your police record yes you get
this like thing that basically
says hey i'm in it i'm of innocence
and the bullet's like oh no i can't
[ __ ] with that i feel like you ripped
off some of my technology
okay okay we can be partners yeah i feel
like in this day and age you can almost
use like uh the tick tock algorithm to
expedite that process and go through
people's social media posts
off of it
it's definitely they can they can detect
burner accounts
right christian's going to be in trouble
i know yeah they can't
but yeah how could we support bypass
security yeah how do you know they can't
detect burners because have you seen the
comment sections and the amount of
burner accounts there are everywhere
no because they have a thing to where
like if you block they delete them right
oh yeah that i thought you meant like it
just detects people who are have burner
accounts yeah if you block no if you
block someone it prevents them from
making any like they can still make a
burner account but their burner account
will be blocked by there because it's
the same phone why do you have a burner
there's a lot of people that have
burners a lot of people i just i was
just curious as to why
just uh i originally had one be too
because i would just post [ __ ] that i
couldn't post on my normal [ __ ] there
which was called a finster yeah i feel
like there's a difference between a
finsta and a burner the celebrity's got
like two oh yeah like kevin durant yeah
celebrity celebrities have fenced us so
they can like interact with their
friends yeah yeah and like
uh
they're big in high school when you're
in follow people you can you have a
little of a feed where you're like
following thoughts or something where
like i don't know i can't think of any
examples but some celebrities wouldn't
want nor yeah they want to like watch
these people i don't know don't listen
it's okay
is a fake instagram account people
usually use it almost as though it is
your second account where you post stuff
that you want to post but some people
feel as though their main account is too
like it's almost like uh too official
for it they don't want to put stupid
[ __ ] that they think is funny or like
it's too much of a professional account
yeah uh but a few years ago people
actually found out that the artist lord
had a finster where she just post photos
of avocados royals yeah royals
yeah so she just had a random fence
account dedicated to avocados and she'd
rate the avocados that she had that day
really yeah i don't really i don't know
how people figured it out what an odd
but they found out and she confirmed
that she's like yeah i mean i [ __ ] with
lord but that is very that's hilarious
you've seen the south park where lord is
actually played by stan's dad no not the
whole time like that's like
he's cause she's such a mystery
yeah i don't really
i don't know what she looks like she's
super young yeah she was young when she
came out with uh that song she popped
off really early in her life not uh
she's
l-o-r-d-e i want to say she's australian
right or new zealand
oh no meatball had her go back
no go back to the
she's only 25 then she has every right
to post avocados and [ __ ] that's a 25
year old thing is it though so if i was
avocados if i was running an avocado
page would that be fine
yeah granite i'm 26. actually can't you
am i not allowed to have a party level
is [ __ ] higher than most
people yeah
it means it's just like you you carry
yourself in a very
mature way yeah i know i keep using the
word mature but old soul also soul yeah
that's a that's a really good yeah yeah
old souls are really good now meatball
on the other hand
you're a [ __ ] wreck
you know that yeah that's nice you got a
burner account and then you're burning
i'm
making something a shorter meatball
there's a guy
i'll just put it in post there's a guy
named matt lucas who like love matt
lucas any relation to david lucas we
should not like matt lucas oh sorry i
have literally seven accounts of his
blocked on my thing and he uses the same
profile picture every time and like
every king in the sting video he's just
like is this a random person or just
some random dude who's like no he's
obsessed with me no it's not a random
person it's actually my burner account
it'd be funny if it was real
i wonder if he deleted the accounts but
i literally deleted account what is it
named
operation sandbag
sandbag operation it's literally just
for me
sandbagger
uh no no spaces sandbag operation oh
sandbag operation oh sandbag operation
or operation sandbag he has both
he has no spacers
there it is i think that's it right yeah
that guy
matt lucas
zero followers zero
following zero people zero positions so
he do i will fight you mac lucas i
[ __ ] hate this guy so he did why does
he not like you i don't know he
dedicates his time to hating on you yeah
i
like uh i think i just saw a new account
while i hadn't seen him for a while but
i i just blocked him and like didn't
give him the bait but uh
i don't know i love blocking
you know why i'm just doing them a favor
just helping them out yeah i'm just
helping you out because you seem to
you know i've seen them be bugging you
yeah you're guiding them yeah let me
just guy let me just help you out let me
let me help your day out let me just
block you that's smart you know because
now you don't have to think about me
oh look what i did for you that's what
that's why i love blocking out like
block party see for the most part i've
gone i've gotten over blocking people
but at the same time i don't look at
anything every now and then now that
instagram has that new feature where
like anyone you follow their
notification goes to the top you know
what i mean oh yeah yeah so like with
that i can see now i can see what other
people that i follow
post
under one of my posts so i i'll keep
track pushes yeah so and then like
everyone else's is at the bottom which
is good because before i just stopped
replying to people in general yeah and
now i can if someone says something that
cracks me up oh i [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] post it yeah you know what
i mean someone said a funny comment to
me about my four thousand dollar guitar
collection and i haven't stopped
laughing at it it's five thousand five
thousand all right
let's get it straight do you not count
chin's guitar as a part of your
collection
what's the origin of the
fourth
thousand dollar collection why'd that
become a joke
it was a fighter in the kid thing yeah
it was a fighter in the kid thing
because that's not true before guitar
collection that wasn't especially when
you got it ready hold on all right
it will explain yeah he goes
he goes there's a new ocean's eleven
movie gonna be it's gonna be a heist
coming after that guitar collection
that is funny
i had to pin that comment immediately
because i love those oceans movies the
[ __ ] bed oh i love you how do you
feel about the remake
with the with uh sandra bullock and all
those things all the girls
the ladies
you didn't see it
yeah meatball that's crazy you got a
burner account have you not
no i haven't seen it i don't i don't
know it wasn't it wasn't very good it
wasn't very good
you know see
[Music]
and i don't think it wasn't good because
they were ladies it wasn't good because
like you don't realize you know why
those are never good because it seems
like it never works it's because they're
trying to do something that was already
made yeah you take from that whereas
like if you just made your own thing yes
exactly then you could stand on your own
you don't even have to be associated
i don't know why like we live in this
world where it's like well we don't have
a
a black version of this so let's make a
black version like or just make a dope
black yeah thing or female thing like
that's
and that's how you stand on your own
that's how you stand
because then you're just associated with
this movie or this thing that people
love so much and then you're like well
uh
why don't we do uh a [ __ ] you know
whatever asian version of this yeah i'm
just listening to everything so i so i
know that i can fit everybody in
native american i don't want to rule
anybody out
what i'm getting at yes but it's just
like just make a dope damn nick you own
one i might throw up oh okay nick it's
all good yeah if you got a balance you
got to balance come back yeah yeah yeah
don't know what's good it's all good
i'll throw up on camera don't wanna we
had a little buck in here
he literally just started puckering his
lips like
what's he
i'm afraid to take wait are you
salivating right now like right before
you need to throw up your mouth kind of
salivates i don't know you know what it
is it's the shrooms in ashwagandha mixed
it definitely empty stomach a little bit
of magic mind a little bit of shrooms 90
there's a lot of magic in my stomach
right now
it's the [ __ ] magic castle down there
anyways yeah
no no
you guys have oh do you have the
connection wait see what it's pretty
easy to get the magic castle oh no it's
only you know what it is
yeah it's like the the thing
he goes
i think he wanted to say castle but that
would have been
anything where you go see magic in the
castle yeah it basically is
what were you talking about oh so i was
saying
do you remember i want that ocean's 11
movie to come out where they take my
guitar collection
and i want to be there when they try to
when they arrive
it's just you
bike
yes in your apartment in an apartment i
know
i've been waiting literally just an
apartment in los angeles california
if there was one movie that you would
want hollywood to remake what would it
be
uh i don't know i like
i like the movies i like where they
stand yeah usually and i like i just
watch it again
that's what i'm saying
that's that's exactly what i'm saying
yeah i'll just watch that hoe again
you know many times i watch tombstone
i have two 15 times nine
i have two
what
you need a bucket no i'm good oh i feel
like the more you look at him the more
he's gonna want to throw i don't know
i'm trying not to distract from the
general conversation
you're fine though yeah i think i'm okay
yeah i think i think you're fine yeah
yeah i think maybe all right names
i'm just kidding
lucky charm
i think maybe to distract nick from it
maybe we
could i mean
actually none of mine was gonna say
maybe we could place i'm smarter than a
fifth grader but we have oh i'd crush
that right now let's see how well he
goes
let's let's hit nick with some [ __ ]
trivia yeah all right that's why i said
name 10 serials but
that's usually when you you pinned on
tops of on top of your body and they
poke your forehead you ever done that
you never
ostrich were you uh
all right so i didn't even see the
choices wait wait wait hold on wait yeah
that's why i'm waiting wait what is this
i don't know okay so we are going to
blow it off with questions
and giant
oh i didn't know you were do i didn't
know you were doing this right now i was
telling her a story yeah no i know
that's why i didn't say anything oh i
got to tell your story
oh
this is such a chaotic episode
i was just i was just waiting yeah i was
just waiting for listening to
chappelle's story and often i just hear
nick ostrich
was like that's the audio listeners are
so confused
everyone's so confused right now you
know what hey we'll do this yeah let's
let's let's put it on nick
yeah
no it was just a dumb thing about like
if you ever did that to your sibling
where you like pin them down and then
hold their hands back and you have to
hit them in the head and you have to
tell them to name 10 cereals no
all right let's go back to nick
to you right now do it [ __ ]
hey do it i would pay my sisters a
dollar to let me do wrestling moves on
them oh really
hey
to wrestle and they didn't continue to
do it on a bigger level my sisters yeah
that's hilarious think about it i was
professionals it was just a nine to five
for them i was the one
they were freelancing
they were freelance wrestlers damn nick
was giving him that word
[Laughter]
i was like counting my change yeah i
want to do the lion table they're like
you're a dime short this time
all right so oh these are like multiple
choice yeah so
let's go nick the question is what is
the fastest bird on foot your options
are an ostrich sparrow
eagle
dragon or woodpecker i know the answer
but i'll let nick go for it oh nick
already went
uh he did yeah i i bet their top speed
is 45 miles an hour look that up also
don't don't don't give him any help
don't
i'll be your lifeline though how do you
spell all search it was just uh ostrich
43. that's awesome wait how do you know
that i know my birds he he's he's
definitely watched uh
not flight speed land speed i feel like
you're a man who used to watch the
crocodile hunter oh yeah or like
amanda's discovery yeah the discovery
channel all right okay we did this one
yeah we did this one uh
okay
i mean we're not gonna do that one
because you can count that yeah makes no
sense what was the
what was the question a heptagon is a
shape with how many signs
[Laughter]
why the [ __ ] would they show the picture
yeah
for reference some people still won't
get it okay your options are four that's
so late let's get
he's on shrooms he knows how he can
count
hell yeah nick you're killing it you're
doing great you're amazing
all right nick how long is one regular
term for a u.s representative see i
actually well and what are the options
read the uh three two
one why start with three i don't know
two
four or six
i get them all mixed up um
like because the numbers are like senate
[ __ ] sometimes i think threes dudes i
know yeah well to be fair if you read
the question again it tells you
who they're looking for uh
how long is one
so house of representatives
is that is that six
i love how cat's trying to be all nice
and like help him out because he's on
track hey i don't know the answer to
this i'm gonna say six six set and
sentence every two years
you wanna say six six
damn i was pretty confident with six
there's something that's a tough
question that is tough but there's
something in there that someone has six
years yeah someone has six years
no
[Music]
senate is definitely everyday judiciary
does it oh wait no aren't there
terms like supreme judges i was already
oh yeah until they want to leave
senators i can't read it okay
senators have sexier terms
wow
okay next question
we're learning
sorry just nick's face i know nick is
just they're his eyes right now he's
just like
all right which of the following states
is not on the gulf of mexico
we got georgia
texas florida
alabama and louisiana easy answer yeah
there's also a photo of the map yeah for
all of your audio listeners
just for reference we're not gonna we're
not gonna show it though
nick is currently
very focused why is this
yes nick it's the easy answer
let him see the map maybe
i think it's a good idea
it's fine it's like four or fifth
graders it's easy don't no no no see the
map
come on he's on truth that's what makes
it fun to go to the options
okay
i feel like they are
what is the question
i feel like they all are but what's the
question
which one of these states are not on the
gulf of mexico that's what i thought it
was okay
i mean you're doing great answers right
there you're doing great you're doing
great on the golf which one of these
it's not it's not
come on you got this is it in or on in
or on either way
do not look at that map
no i'm not i'm trying to see the
question without giving away the map
there we go
again george's georgia texas florida
alabama and louisiana
you got this i would say christian just
gave you a hint too
i did yeah oh [ __ ] i didn't even mean to
i know you didn't mean to but you did
i feel like this is the moment you need
an editor to put all the numbers
calculating like an over and over thing
i'm already seeing though
[Laughter]
and he keeps like when we scroll up and
down then i'm like it's weird
i don't know the answer though you know
this
if you had to take a wild guess
no oh my god nick
alabama louisiana is
georgia nicholas nick
wow he's bringing out the full name
can we pick georgia louise and see what
happens i think he said
show him the map he doesn't look like
he's gonna know
yeah i don't know i feel like they're
all
you thought so
something's confusing
songs almost over god damn it wait wait
no no it goes in fine
i get this
he's so part though think uh
that's fine he's not true he's not a
little all right
[Music]
georgia okay i'm with nick
no i don't know
oh you just did that on purpose oh you
what is the answer it's got to be
georgia thank you it's george
good job nick no no no no think about it
because louisiana cut
i was [ __ ] up because i i initially
thought alabama then i was like no no
it's not alabama because georgia's more
up north yeah up north i mean this is a
terrible map to show yeah that isn't
weird
can we see a map of the united
states but then you have to see all this
yeah yeah states and everything state
map of the united states
i mean you tried your best
i mean no that is a hard question yeah
no no that's fine yeah
oh i see you see
so you yeah florida
oh
cause because i didn't think alabama for
a second but then i realized
that georgia's two yeah see in my head
georgia and arkan georgia was arkansas i
thought they were back to back and both
touching the water oh got it yeah and
alexander
was louisiana no what is the left
mississippi i was thinking georgio
yeah
well you got it right
yeah this he kept scrolling past this
and then you go up and like my vision i
couldn't like yeah because i was like i
know i know
he's on the phone i didn't want you to
see the map but i didn't realize that
you seeing the map wouldn't have done
any difference because it's a terrible
map
but
next question
i don't even know the longest testing
i'm out i have no idea how much time do
you think has passed right now i know
oh [ __ ]
see i that's a great question like me
not thinking about it but i feel
probably 40 minutes right now i don't
know what do you think 42 no dude you
are right man you're dialed in on sir
are you ready man
yeah
i joked to mike now i was like call me
sean kepp uh because i'm i'm the new
brain man i was like excited get here he
goes i'll call you dustin hoffman okay
good that was like a sick bird
nick is on rain magic mine weed and
shrooms
how nick is still functioning right now
i have no idea maybe that's what keeps
him up though if he didn't have all this
stuff he'd probably be like just a
zombie
i feel like it's just so high
functioning yeah what is the lowest
prime number this one i'm out i totally
forgot prime number one chin and cat
should know it's one oh well there we go
there we go oh wow
that's after dark episode prime number
is something that isn't divisible i
think i know yes it is nick
i think i know it
i think
it's what two
what about zero god damn it i don't
think is zero technically a number if i
record this i can't
how am i going to recover from this
that's me right now
there's a uh my
scott what's his name that reaches out
and offers to do deep fakes
welsh he's actually 50 from like 40
minutes away from my hometown but i want
to we should have defect that yeah
how am i going to recover from this
so a prime number is a whole number
greater than one with only two factors
it's themselves and one so oh so like
see i count i got one as a prime number
i don't know if i'm gonna explain it
like right but like it's the factors are
two are two like to get the number like
it's two times one i'm still lost i
think i i could be explaining it wrong
like like like five is
i don't know
i lost it i'm still i'm i'm not
perfect it's safe to say that we still
are not smarter
this week but one of these weeks we will
be i know how to tip
i don't know
and what else is but you get tripped up
on prime numbers because
yeah i don't have to think about [ __ ]
prime numbers when i'm tipping but uh
you're whipping like if i'm tipping
someone oh
one well technically two is a problem
[Music]
what are we doing i'm listing prime
numbers i'm listing prime numbers i
wonder if this is correct it is uh uh
i'll do it again one hey yeah yeah don't
hold on wait wait wait wait have him
look it up let me pull it up
keep your eyes closed
go for it nick
one
two three five seven eleven thirteen
seventeen nineteen
that's already incredible twenty is
twenty one
or i mean
twenty
amazing that's amazing yeah you just
named that much i remember this yeah we
also did not prepare any of this yeah so
it's not like there's some people at
home memorized there's some people at
home are like yeah mr sandbag no yeah
but i mean how do we remember this hey
[ __ ] those people that are like yeah
[Laughter]
just like rain maze like
just like rain man
he just puts his head down one three
um this is a better definition of it
though it's a prime number so it's a
number that can only be divided by
itself and one is a prime number
it has to be greater than
one one
yeah
and it can't have any remainders
so
there we go
now i know what if now i know what a
problem is i still knock it all right
let's see i'm not going
what is the largest south american
country by area
oh brazil
there are the options are argentina
brazil chile mexico
coincidentally we just looked this up on
well we looked up how big brazil was on
the sting like it was yesterday oh okay
so you know but but i would have known
anyways it's like
well you're right yeah [ __ ] what is it
yeah
what's the
what square footage or what
uh they were just square my biggest one
like oh oh square mileage is 3.2 million
yeah oh yeah i remember okay
see that [ __ ] always confuses me
whenever they're talking about like
area look of a state like square mileage
is like three million like so how big is
it really
you know
is that a dumb question and also popular
okay i like how he pauses
because the way that nick looked at me i
was like wait is that a dumb question i
think to be fair none of us actually
knows yeah
i think that's why we're all silent we
also do not yeah i'm just saying like
like why say square mileage just say how
big the [ __ ] area is you know
how would you describe it though like
i wanted i want to dissect this
go ahead i want no no like i want to i
want to help you understand violence
so east west it's a certain amount of
mileage yeah north to south certain
amount of amount of miles and then
that's it
that's it
but that's what that's what square
mileage is but what's the whole squaring
coming from why why can't they just say
hey it's 100 miles west to east west
within the
you you know within the range
of the square i was like vicinity
i get i got it i got a guy all right all
right i understand both of you guys you
know square inches not off the top of my
head right now no it's just an inch by
inch it's like you're saying an inch
east inch west so the squared is because
you're doing it in both directions
like so like so oh so you're multiplying
east to west north by south and then
that's what the square mileage is yeah x
and y axis
you better keep the same smart energy
next week
this is the smartest nickname this
better not because of the shrooms dog i
really do feel like you could be a great
teacher
i i in a really [ __ ] up way no no i
thought about that a lot but i was like
there's too much of a when i was young
like what are you gonna do i like i like
it but there's like a ceiling on how
much [ __ ] you can handle
yeah yeah do you make a lot of money as
a professor though i don't
i feel like it depends on what uh
college yeah uh
if you're at harvard i still always
looked at like salaries i'm like there's
like a ceiling on how much
this can make where i feel like i'm in
the thing where it's like i don't know
there's no ceilings 641
64 to 340.
that's great type in type in uh at
harvard
oh [ __ ]
what is i can't see sorry
yeah so six hundred thousand
six hundred sixty eight thousand but
average they make like one two a hundred
and twenty two thousand it's still not
bad
better than that i wonder who the
average teacher teacher is at harvard
though
i've been highest-paid professor at
harvard if i went to i love that versus
the pinnacle
say what yeah nothing
nick
you gotta say it i said if i went to
school for eight years and made 120
thousand dollars a year i would put a
bullet yeah before i'd be like 100 grand
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
4.3 33 million oh my goodness
at columbia but listen he's a teacher
he's teaching all these people to do all
this crazy [ __ ] oh he's a doctor yeah
one yeah it probably depends on
obviously what the [ __ ] you're teaching
a gynecologist 3.3 mill not bad annually
obviously right yeah because if you're
just teaching communications
what's up
takashi 69
takahashi
takahashi
i keep in my head economics i have i'm
like
this is all i feel like we're like
have something to do but we don't we're
just talking
welcome to vodka
we'll edit this out so we don't look
like losers but he did want to uh
have people zoom in just no one has
responded oh
good hey i'm having fun yeah i'm
actually kind of glad because the pain
in the ass i want to have to deal with
some [ __ ] hick in the midwest i
wouldn't have to work for this job that
i have uh
yeah yeah exactly
i just want to chat it up with you guys
yeah that's
you get ten percent of the show we need
someone
on the ones of twos dude
one thing i do want to do in a week or
two is have uh
just a quick zoom in with james bachera
the magic mind see you oh yeah
i like that he's mad funny yeah and he's
got he's got a crazy story too like
he's out he has a podcast below the line
uh
that he talks to like other people in
silicon valley and stuff but like to a
regular person his story is nuts like i
don't know just what he went through
yeah that'd be interesting um
easy
which one of the following is not part
of the four corners easy i sneezed
i didn't know his cat no that's crazy
nick this is too easy yes i'm gonna
sneeze out yeah i can't it's my favorite
shoe what like
i can't just yeah because it's just in
case you're [ __ ] oh you're the same yeah
we're just gonna wait it out next time
i'll be ready can you explain that nick
why is sneezing your favorite thing like
i just love the i don't know it's like
you like these or you like when other
people sing i love i love okay all right
okay they said there's some sort of like
just like
i guess it's some somewhat related to an
orgasmic no no i i read that i get what
he means i i feel him on i like to
sneeze bug i was wondering if he meant
he likes
other people to sneeze that's why i was
like that's a little weird but i will
say like if someone holds in their
sneeze it like bothers me yeah
like nailed down because i have terrible
allergies
so i am sneezing left to right all the
time declared that clear oh my god
clairton barely works for me anymore
really i don't know what it is it's just
that clarity if i could get me right and
it's so frustrating because stevie
doesn't have any allergies to anything
so he doesn't understand it but every
time i sneeze or my sister's yes because
we both have terrible allergies he gets
annoyed he's like what's happening like
just go pop a pill and you should be
fine like no that's not how this works
[ __ ] i don't really choose
yeah my eyes are itchy i don't know
congested
like allergies like you just that is
horrible i'm not meant to survive that's
yeah like on a biological level i should
not be here
like like i have bad ideas
in other states medical communities like
property because like for me in arizona
my [ __ ] uh allergies are real bad but
there's a lot of dust in arizona i have
a theory that it's because biologically
i'm not where i'm supposed to be like
i'm not supposed to be in l.a or san
jose when i'm in vietnam my allergies
are gone i never have a [ __ ] issue
yeah my skin is nice it's bright it's
glowy but then i come here and there's
so many health issues and i think it's
because biologically i shouldn't be here
damn
that's crazy that's my theory
i've told y'all everything that's very
everything
has a ton of
like you know just
yeah there's always something going on
because i feel like i wonder
what if she goes back to vietnam and
just like she's in perfect health
just like that because i remember going
to uh my family used to make one really
big trip to vietnam with everybody
extended family so like 30 of us would
be on the same plane kids are running
around for 16 hours
and we would all visit our family who
are still in vietnam
and when i was there i had really bad
acne in high school i used to have the
like emo bangs to cover it up and that
one summer and sophomore year i left
vietnam after staying there for two
months and my all of my acne was gone
all of my acne scars were [ __ ] gone
within those two months
and i think it's because i'm supposed to
be in vietnam like i'm not supposed to
be here that type of climate that
happens
because my body's like yes this is where
you're supposed to be both of your
parents are from here you thrive in this
climate
but i refuse
so i get it
is there any place that has like a
similar to vietnamese um i would say
because hawaii is kind of similar uh
florida's kind of similar because it's a
tropical humid climate
but i don't know it's just i think it's
the water there maybe the communism too
you just gotta take like a week vacation
to one of those other places uh and see
if it clears up like it did like every
time you go there it takes away one
allergy one allergy you know what i mean
yeah just one i wonder if i should be in
africa
see if you were in africa though don't
say go back to your country
if you're just like you have a bad glow
up you're in there your skin's [ __ ]
glowing you lose all this well you're
[ __ ] shredded you're doing three
backflips in a row
i'm singing like a con yeah
convic
music music
god i love
all on the floor
[Laughter]
discovered lady gaga he did he did yeah
i lit a little bit too much i didn't
know that uh uh i [ __ ] with lady gaga
yeah she was a writer for a while uh
after she signed a record deal with i
forgot who it was oh cause he's on her
first biggest hit yeah i just danced
just dance she's she's one of those
uh that i remember those rumors she said
in an interview that it does like
colored my like i think of that
someone born with both men and uh male
and female genitalia yeah
that exists yeah it's very rare but it
does exactly
hey megan fox is a hermaphrodite for a
while too you get an exercise she's got
she's got goofy yeah she got uh the the
uh murderer's thumb yeah it looks like
someone took a hammer to her thumb and
just i feel like it's just like an easy
room like but i don't know how these
people get these like they get it spread
like like wildfire has has she ever
addressed that she did lady gaga or
megan fox uh megan fox i'm not sure i
did see an interview with lady gaga
earlier in her career because it was uh
circulating on my feed where a reporter
asked her like oh well is are the rumors
true are you a hermaphrodite
hermaphrodite do you have a dick and he
was so like str it was inappropriate he
wasn't trying to be rude but it was just
inappropriate you had to hear these
rumors right you know like
this is the moment where
oh yeah
but she was answering it and i think
this is when she really started building
up like a lgbt fan base because she says
who the [ __ ] cares if i do or i don't it
doesn't matter to me and my fans don't
care about that so why should i answer
it and that's like all she said on the
matter and then she wrote this away and
it's just
what's crazy it's like yeah like to what
nick said how the [ __ ] does one just
start that and then people just ride for
it i know this is true yeah because
based off her response she's like why
does it matter okay but also
no but
listen i love people that do that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] with people it's like uh it's
like in a remember the titans sunshine
yeah when he was like he was like are
you gay he's like okay because i don't
care if you
if you are not he goes he's like if you
don't care then why are you asking he's
like uh
i love when people do [ __ ] like that but
that's like because it is it is annoying
because it's like it's just an
open-ended answer yeah it's just like
well [ __ ] just why i wonder how
people started that
right this was kind of before the
internet was as big as it is now like
how did word just spread like wildfire i
remember those rumors growing up i
remember the rumors of jessica uh
what's her name the really jessica
yes having herpes i remember that was
one what how
she was also in that what was that
[ __ ] movie honey
oh
yeah yeah she was in uh what's that into
the blue with paul walker great movie
great movie is it great though
i liked it don't you dare talk [ __ ]
about it i'm not talking [ __ ] about it
it was a great like it doesn't mean
everybody has to like yes it does you
guys heard my way the highway
14 year old girlfriend or something
about that oh yeah
yeah i think we were you and i were
talking about this off air once
yeah he's kind of wild because when you
think of people who date paul walker
well he was the actor who passed away
from fast and furious yeah yeah uh i had
the biggest crush on him as a child and
i was so excited i was talking to stevie
about this how like now oh my god i had
the biggest question on my channel too
right fine as [ __ ]
i was talking to stevie about how he i
was so hyped when i found out that he
had a girlfriend at the time he was 30
in his 30s very early 30s he was in
hawaii and he met a girl while he was on
vacation there she was on vacation with
her parents she was a 16 year old girl
and they started dating with her parents
like blessing and they we're together
she loves paul walker how she's painting
this love story
no he did this yeah tell us what
happened
it's true okay i didn't hear how old he
was so he was in his early 30s like
maybe 30 32 and she was 16. i remember
at the time i was very young i was
younger than 16. so to me a 16 year old
was an adult essentially and i thought
that was the coolest [ __ ] ever it was
like i have a chance he likes them young
he's so excited but now that i'm older i
was like oh that [ __ ] was weird
just a random girl she wasn't like a
actress or anything just a random girl
who was on vacation with her parents and
they were
together 33 at the time
and she was the girlfriend he was with
when he actually passed away
so they still ended up together for a
long time wait that's the that's that's
his last girlfriend when he passed away
she was 28. was he when he passed away
oh in his fourth so they oh so they were
together for years yeah they ended up
together for years but apparently he
dated like 16 euro another 16 year old
before her as well what so this isn't
like a one-off
damn sweet oh is she like out of the
limelight yeah she's not like a famous
person at all she was just like no one
knows what she looks like uh no there
are photos of her but she's not like
you want to see her on instagram or
anything unless you knew who she was and
went out of your way to look for her
that's why i painted it as a love story
because to me it was yes
it was a love story set the context of
what you feel i just had to do the
outside of like what yeah no i love that
point of view because you're right
you're absolutely right um
the
podcast i do with pat and dill and i
reference it all the time because it's
like the only other thing i do with my
time but
pat does a segment called
uh
did you know aren't you glad you're dead
aren't you glad you're dead and hafner
would be in there yes he's done hugh
hefner he's on hugh hefner he deadpool
so this is the girl yeah
jesus that's i don't even know that
i knew everything about him i loved him
i know so cat so if you went back wait
so that
huh
cat since you
oh
now that you know what you know yeah
if you went back so you now you think
it's kind of gross or kind of like it is
gross but a part of me still finds them
so attractive i feel like i would date
them so if you were still if you were 16
right now i'd be like conflicted if i
was 16 oh my god yes absolutely you know
now yes okay yeah yeah there you go i
would 16 you would have gone yes you
would pause
those blue eyes chin i didn't
yeah her parents were cool with it
that is such a good picture but you know
like what he just i'm just focusing on
his backlash
look i just want to cover her up and
just look at him
she's just looking at him too yeah
wow
good looking man i know he's very good
looking man yeah
and even the way she's looking at him
it's impossible not to look at paul
walker yeah picture what a great picture
he's just struggling he's like rugged
there actually and he's like oh [ __ ]
yeah
it's weird because i don't i don't have
much to say like it i mean her parents
are the ones that gave the [ __ ]
okay yeah
then what do you do and there is like
the age of consent in certain states is
16. so it's like i don't know i don't
know it's just a little weird but yeah
whatever it is weird but i don't know
yeah i just i think like collected with
this
i don't know dude young the entire idea
behind the law is you don't want
like
fully grown adults manipulating the mind
of a young undeveloped yeah exactly and
so there could be cases where it
actually is developed mind but there has
to be a line somewhere yeah and you draw
it and if the guy is perpetually
crossing that line for whatever reason
like why you got to do that you know
yeah
how many times can you fall in love just
[ __ ] with the 16 year old that's
another thing that's kind of weird out
of this is paul walker you got to put it
into perspective of this is one of the
like most popular guys in hollywood
who can have anyone he wants anyone man
or woman and he decides to date a 16
year old that he met in hawaii i thought
she'd be cuter
that's what a lot of people have said
come on
i mean to be dating paul walker i'm with
chipotle
let's we'll cut that out
i thought she'd be cuter
you know i'm a mushroom so i can be like
unfiltered please
but everybody was thinking
yeah me
so that's why i actually do believe it i
think he was in love with this girl
yeah
i don't even know what to [ __ ] say
about that but i love it i love you
untrue
i don't know oh you dated christina
emiliano i feel like this is what i'm
talking about like
literally anyone he wants christina
christine christina
what was her first hit that video oh
she's in like oil and [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's like an asian theme yeah she's
like oh my gosh she's gorgeous
amg pm was another bop can we look up uh
christina milian the video that we're
all like reminiscing about yeah
how do you spell last name uh
m-i-l-l-l
a-n i would imagine
i know and it's a one-nil
that was her that was the first big
hitch yet right i think so and the only
one dip it low you didn't like aim to pm
somebody from a uh yeah okay okay okay
how can you forget
okay yeah we got two we got two
everything else can be argued about two
hard hitters
i may or may not okay listen i love that
[ __ ] dumb movie
which one what love got to do with it uh
love don't call something i love don't
yes with her nick cannon yeah that was
gonna love that movie
she's tiny too right yes
i think she wasn't bringing i wanted to
bring it on yeah she was in one of them
the later ones that got kind of weird
[Music]
can you turn it down
oh i actually went back i was in her
no you remember something different huh
yeah
i remember a different video too where i
thought she was super sexy but i would
never think of the same one man i wonder
if it's a.m to pm maybe
i was actually at uh her house what once
last year because stevie and i like to
do this thing to kill time in uh la when
i still lived in l.a hold on wait
there's a guy fixing my there's a guy
fixing my air conditioning i think i
missed it too i think it was too long
ago
it's not that it's definitely not that
song are you sure definitely not that
song i hope he calls me back definitely
sorry
fixing your ass
but he's in my house he's like call me
now uh
steve and i really liked going to open
houses to kill time on the weekends and
we were looking at a house in agora
hills and my favorite thing to do is
pretend to be like his bimbo girlfriend
so they ask him questions yeah uh and we
were at a house in this area just like
looking randomly it was a beautiful like
three four million dollar house and
there were a bunch of mtv like awards on
a shelf in the studio and i was just
looking at it like huh i wonder who this
is and i didn't recognize the name
initially i was kind of looking around
like oh this is a really pretty house we
left i looked up what the name was it
was her i think her current husband or
her fiance's so i went on her instagram
page and i see the same staircase i'm
like i was in
christina milian's house so then she's
like i don't need to sing [ __ ] do the
dance and sing songs i'm married to like
i'm married to this guy
yeah beautiful house so he's like a
mogul what do you know
i think is he in the music industry
he has something to do with i think
dancing with the stars or like he
produces some music i don't know he's
not a big time producer probably i don't
even think he's that big but he is
successful yeah i don't think you would
know him off the top of your head
because he looked at some of his uh
working you'd realize yeah
damn
i think the streams are like going away
good man
just ease into what's going on now yeah
yeah
nice little comment i don't need you
throwing up in my car yeah should we
tell them what you did yesterday
how would you do you in my car oh that
was awesome
[Laughter]
why are you telling me
[Laughter]
are you thinking of cassie me and you no
no wait wait what what i love her
what was the description
describing she was oiled up i thought oh
maybe i am i'm getting him mixed up now
for you because cassie winner did kind
of have the same type of vibe when they
were
wearing like a sphinx type of things
okay maybe i am thinking me and you but
christine and millian's video
passing it's all good cassie's me and
you
what happened in meatballs car
neck
what did you type in
oh hey nick nick
nick
cheers man oh cheers
that's why i wanted to tell the story
because it will make it even funnier
sorry i'm sorry i forgot we were on a
podcast
tell the story oh uh we saw we drove
home and we saw brendan on the 101 like
and it was like
away from here it wasn't like oh we just
[ __ ] just both hopped on like it was
kind of a random seeing at the same time
probably like it was like vint like the
north like the ventura like santa monica
split like by the sherman oaks galleria
and we see brennan's uh car it was just
really randomly see him on the highway
awesome so
nick just look it's like kind of quiet
in the car nick just slowly turns to me
and goes
pull next one i'm gonna moon him
you mooned him
and it was like a hassle to do
it took forever yeah i moved so many
more people before
and the funniest thing is
we were literally driving next to b's
car for about two minutes three minutes
nick's bare ass out the window i was
leaning on the horn to get his attention
and he never looked over what was he
it's hard to hear the whole idea was he
just driving i was very impressed with
meatballs driving
he because brendan got ahead of us
and like
he was like okay i'm on it and he like
[ __ ] all of a sudden i don't know i
was like skipping past guards did you
feel like the movie when you're like
follow that car yeah and you're just
like right up so what you but my ass is
out yeah that's the window the whole
time the whole time
you're like oh balance 101. oh did i bro
it's [ __ ] dead i mean
there was no surprisingly there was no
traffic yeah it was traffic but not too
too bad yeah i could do it like if you
were aggressive you could be the [ __ ]
that who's weaving through that's what
was happening we weren't like flying
yeah he was he was making moves and we
got we got up right next to him
and brandon
when he finally saw it he was like
why is it so hairy
what so he yelled it out over there yeah
he rolled down his window and he's like
why is he so hairy no freaking way but
can you imagine if they were awesome in
bumper-to-bumper traffic yeah
you just gotta hold your ass up
just to get the bridge
[Laughter]
and the fact that you you ever get your
ass up in that oh yeah that bmw for a
long time and balancing it i thought he
was going to go out the window for a
minute it was an ordeal but it was worth
it
the look on brennan's face when it
because he kind of like looked over
quick because they started leaning on
the horn again
and he looked over then looked away and
did a double take looked back and
started dying laughing i missed all that
obviously yeah
you're getting the job done yeah
i i thought to myself i was like i'm 34
years old this this this is timeless i
could be 80. yeah oh yeah it would never
get old
yeah yeah i honestly i haven't known
anyone to do that in a minute but
yeah when's the last year yeah you've
seen someone in the fact that he's like
man i'm gonna move him yeah they took me
off guard too i was like wait not even
like not even just like because now you
would just think your [ __ ] would
just wave
nick said no i'm a mooner yeah we
literally just like oh look there's bee
dead quiet for a minute or two he just
looked like slowly too it sounded like
it was like we were talking about
mooning yeah i loved it i love the story
you [ __ ] nerd no but he we
you did just randomly bring it up it's
not like we were talking about moon and
we saw him and it was like a little
quiet like i'm gonna moon him
it took me so off guard that nick my
boss
was [ __ ]
i like hearing that oh no your boss
yeah i don't know why nick's like oh
yeah
i think we looked at the org chart of
thick boy yeah uh i'm like some
satellite
[Laughter]
so i don't think i have your yeah
direct replacement my a higher
i kind of want to see like a podcast
family tree i think it's like all the
comedy podcasts and then like branches
out into like the other multiple shows
oh no you you said family trick for a
second i thought you were going to say
you kind of wanted to see what nick's
ass looked like which i was gonna be no
no no i'm okay yeah i think we're all
good i don't know how i don't know how
you got that i didn't see it thank god
yeah i don't know how he got that either
yeah i don't know how you got there oh
he just automatically goes to the yeah
yeah you go
that's the thing about meatball he just
goes [ __ ] all the way yeah
[ __ ] one way and i'm like how do you
get he goes hard left how did so meep
all you saw was
nixon
staring into my eyes i was like okay
i know that's why it was okay all right
what are we at like nick like i'm i do
remember
i do remember like having a switch lanes
and i just remember nick kind of like
trying to like hold shifting and like he
like kind of like lost his balance and
like hit his head on my rear view mirror
but that actually happened what that's a
true story yeah everything yeah
all right i'm just making sure you know
and the other drivers cause you tried to
lie to us earlier so no no no he like
because i did like have to jerk out of
the lane and he kind of stumbled you had
a jerk yeah what about the other drivers
that are there must have been people
seeing it
out the window oh yeah were they
freaking out see i couldn't focus on it
because i was just trying to try to
drive and also see brent's reaction yeah
what huh what are you saying
oh no we're all talking together
[Laughter]
how do you not know what i'm saying
you're not been paying attention
don't go outside no i don't
it's hot it's hot oh it probably is uh i
actually do want to go excite time for
plugs yeah all right let's do it um so
this comes out friday
yeah yes oh so this comes out friday at
what time
p.m eight right eight p.m oh it comes
out at night what i don't know so i'll
already be on stage by the time this
comes out oh yeah
i'll try to get out earl earlier i can't
i can oh if you can i mean yeah where
are you salt lake city yeah well i'll
put it out earlier i always try to post
it at 7 8
cause i'm like we're after dark and it's
like no that's why if that's the
tradition we'll keep oh there's no
there's no treasure i like that i have a
little new deadline because i
procrastinate yeah
and uh i love the honesty yeah
appreciate that i'm the same one
when the episode always drops people do
love it so i have no supervisor on this
yeah yeah
the show could not come out yeah yeah i
wouldn't get a text
people would notice like within the like
our work group that an episode was not
possible mike would hit me up like yeah
pretty quick uh so yeah april 8th friday
and saturday
sorry april 8th and april 9th i'll be in
salt lake city at wise guys comedy club
uh may 6th and 7th i'll be in san diego
california new comedy club called my
drop comedy club i'm doing the opening
weekend of it and then i'll be doing a
one-nighter in the hometown may 12th in
phoenix at stand up live
boom and what is it that you like this
week yeah yeah something
something that you like something
everything you're doing something you
enjoy oh something i enjoy yeah oh you
know something other people should check
out yeah i i don't know i've just been
hiking a lot and all of you guys been
noticing that's a great plug go on a
hike yeah go on a hike i don't know if
you've been noticing my recent figure i
haven't shed much pounds but hey but
you're shedding yeah i'm [ __ ] yeah you
know i ran sprints last night i did 15.
t-shirts are a little looser now yeah
listen i haven't worn this shirt in a
minute i've had it for a minute it's
just been hanging in the closet because
i'm like i am i can't wear it yet and
here you are and here i am i was able to
wear i was so nervous when i put it on
but when it just [ __ ] said hey
welcome back and it's loose on you it's
not a tight fit either
thank you you should be proud of
yourself yeah i have this tattooed on my
arm
uh goddammit why is it only on your
thing
um all right who's got the next plug uh
go on the hike everybody yeah
yeah go ahead uh instagram oh wait oh oh
oh what where what one thing we've been
doing that we like and your plug yep
smoke weed
um ah come on
he played with the medium a little bit
by going a hike but we're talking about
a recommendation like a a tv show oh
okay um my bad i should have said go
higher no i i like that
that was funny
he no no i just ruined it
i didn't know we were doing show
you didn't really ruin it we were doing
a bad day i don't know but i i don't
know but i have to i haven't i have to
break it because i feel bad
i was walking out
no i'm just trying to think like what
show i've been uh come back to me yeah
we'll come back to you uh jack shore he
didn't say it on our show did he he no
he just launched his own podcast he said
he wasn't in the works
yeah it came out like days later yeah
but yeah so check out uh jack shore's
podcast
it's called what tank up or something
tank something
what a horrible plug i know no it's not
horrible plug but yeah no
jack shorts podcast he doesn't have it
on audio players yet and i i dm'd i'm
like if you need help like this is super
easy like we can get the mmi uh nope
it'll be available on audio soon but
check out jack shore's podcast uh i'm
sure you can find it on his instagram if
you guys really want to go and give it a
like yeah yeah
has patty the baddie
cats after dark has jack shore yeah yeah
he's yeah
i
and he's gonna be a champion paddy's not
gonna be champion
i mean
maybe in the future like way in the
future but yeah jack is on his way for
sure absolutely uh and then for personal
plug uh check out another below deck
podcast there's
below deck sailing yacht which is smack
dab in the middle of the season right
now uh for free and then below deck down
under
that peacock down and down no stream if
you're real that's like for the yeah
that's for the hardcore below
you're right that's a great show it's so
much fun to watch i'm serious it is so
much fun to watch
all right
all right so um i have a youtube channel
it's chinsuyi my
if you if you already follow me on
instagram you know how to spell it but
here's i want to say one thing
so i try to do these giveaways i did
like over a thousand dollars worth of
into the m gift cards oh yeah but some
people don't reply to my as soon as i
pick a winner i'm like hey you won and
they don't email me back i'm like just
check back at your comments to make sure
you and i also gave a gopro hero9 away
i gave i was like hey you want it he
never replied back so just reply back
yeah and
you should put like just so you get sued
by some like
you have one week to reply or one no so
i i always comment like i'll give you to
this time yeah please reply back before
i have to give someone else because i
don't want to like obviously yeah so
yeah that's all
yeah oh uh yeah hi my name is kat uh you
can find me on instagram teen only fans
teen and
i recommend going out to watch the movie
x if you are a horror film fanatic it's
a really fun slasher it's so it's not
about dmx i haven't heard about it it's
good
yeah it's in theaters it didn't get that
much promotion but kid cuddies in it uh
britney snow
j i believe her name is jenna ortega she
was in the second season of you a bunch
of other stuff she's great the movie is
so funny
and very logical for how it ends oh okay
i highly recommend i love that movie
uh and then for me instagram see palo 6
i don't know why we all looked at
christian at the same time well you
already did yours no he's coming back
for his uh recommendation yeah himself
i forgot my recommendation but yeah go
for it go ahead no i i have to think of
it so go for it all right so instagram
see payroll 6 and then i know this is
old but uh my recommendation is the
mandalorian i've never watched anything
star i've seen maybe one star wars movie
wasn't a fan of the franchise i started
watching the mandalorian
it's fire so yeah i'd recommend watching
the mandalorian way to way to uh totally
redeem yourself from the smoke smoke
because like i that's how i'm
envisioning this segment is like it
could be old [ __ ] and or [ __ ] that
people have seen and now i may check
that out because i don't like star wars
either yeah
i hate star like i don't hate it it's
just not my cup of tea but that's more
that's more yeah yeah but the way this
is done like it's just so [ __ ] good
like it's really good and i like i said
not not a huge star wars guy like i
tried watching it back in the day didn't
like it tried watching it last year
still didn't like it but this like i've
watched every single episode so far
that's awesome it's really good i can't
wait till we fight a fair one but
anyways you mean you can't wait till you
get your ass beat by me i mean i can't
oh my gosh kick your ass hey chin you
got anything
what are you guys going to compete in we
got to film it put it on the podcast
all about the content we need to get a
map we need to get a map for the studio
seriously for wrestling matches for
everything else oh no i ain't wrestling
i know dude that's what we have to do
there's so much wasted space exactly
that's not a good way to like a lot of
canvas to settle certain grievances too
just like russell
yeah certain grievances like being ugly
hey dude come on like what type of uh
energy drink do we want in the studio do
you want rain do you want monster and
then like wrestle it out it's always
raining
i think it's rain it's raining it's
raining yeah and nick will fight you if
you say otherwise yeah imagine
wait so real quick mine my
recommendation
have has everyone here
seen old boy the korean movie old boy no
okay i've heard good things so
my recommendation is to watch old boy
but do not read about it don't read like
what happens just watch the movie and
watch it
the korean one not the american was it
the 2003 2003 yes it's probably 2003. so
watch the korean with subtitles don't
watch the american one because it
completely destroyed it watch the korean
one don't read about it just watch it it
is insane i'm excited yeah i kind of
want you to offer i kind of want you to
give me a little background about it
it's a revenge story okay
someone gets kidnapped
[Music]
that's all that's all i'm already pissed
i didn't know that much that's all
that's all i just didn't know if it was
like a korean like paranormal movie or
no no it's it's insanely like it it's so
well done the music's amazing is it like
a korean takeaway
you guys are i want to know nothing okay
that's it yeah that is all right
old boy i'm going to text nick
someone gets kidnapped
my favorite thing when i was young it
was like a movie watching come on you're
just like flipping through cable and
like oh a movie star i'm giving nothing
away though what is this dude just watch
it and you didn't know anything and
you'd sit there for two please watch it
understand korean cinema it is amazing
enjoy
all right and there you have it all
right this is why this is why i want to
do that at the top of this show i do
like that
yeah i see what you're saying the
transition is a little weird but yeah no
no no just because like we're we're
almost trying to get out of here but i
think there's a ton of discussion there
oh yeah oh yeah
and what people are enjoying i get it
all right well thank you guys for tuning
in we'll obviously put that at the top
of the show so we can have a no
and uh come to come support my shows and
support every single one of us and all
that we do tonight salt lake city yes
get your tickets
yeah all right
[Music]
[Music]
you